t'énerver
[Musique]
3 l'inégalité des races oui bien sûr
c'est évident toute l'histoire le
démontre elle n'ont pas la même capacité
ni le même niveau d'évolution historique
ce n'est pas raciste du tout qu'est-ce
que veut dire ce photomontage exactement
tout est dit entre les mots
elle arrive comme ça elle débarque comme
ça c'est franchement c'est une sauvage
quoi elle prend tout le monde quand on
lui parle quelque chose de grave à la
télé aux informations n'importe où elle
vous fait un sourire mais il faut voir
un sourire du diable c'est une sauvage
voilà à limite on mange je préfère
l'avoir dans un arbre après les bronches
que de l'avoir comme ça au gouvernement
franchement une photo d'un bateau rempli
de migrants venus d'Afrique et cette
légende peut-être suffirait-il de couler
un ou deux bateaux poubelles en
mouillant quelques mines bien placé des
propos tenus par le candidat du Front
national du canton de
Saint-Chély-d'Apcher en Lozère sur son
compte facebook Jean-François Étienne
que nous avons retrouvé ce matin son
domicile assumé totalement cette
déclaration
puisqu'on est envahi qu'on n'arrive pas
à les arrêter avec des bateaux de guerre
les Italiens avaient même pas les
arrêter avec des bateaux de guerre il
faut les Arte par un moyen ou un autre
tant que je ne serai pas Monsieur
Gilbert à vos yeux tant que je ne serai
pas peint en noir je ne serai pas
ou des propos que tiennent vos
lieutenants ou des propos de vos
militants une part de responsabilité
jamais
[Musique]